Hello, everybody!
My name is Markiplier and
welcome back to Subnautica.
I've still got my Christmas hat!
Even though there hasn't been a Christmas update to this game!!!
III'm still wearing it.
But in this update there has been a new update.
(mark.exe has crashed. Please try again later)
In this video there's a new update
that you all should be aware of.
The precursor update
is now in the game, so when you guys were telling
me, there was a HUUGE
alien temple or something or other
on an island, it's now there
because that was in the developer early access
build of the game, and I'm
playing the RELEASE build of the game,
which is not that. That thing
that that is. So what I'm gonna do is I'm a go back to my
base and then I'm going to put names on the locker
cause I got'em over here (points head) and then I'm gonna
Ehhhhh talk to you guys about
that thing we're talking about over here with the
thing and the thing and the thing. So I don't know why I did the intro here
but, I-uh everybody ignore me I'ma get back to my
base real quick. Alright, hi Karen
OK so now, the Precursor
update is in the game and apparently that brings
along with it NOT ONLY new alien
technology Eeeehuh but the
necessary components to be able to
(The face of terror) eventually
not in this update but kinda like laying
the ground work for the rescue ship
to come get us out of this hell hole
and TAKE US THE FUCK HOME
(Breaks into song)FUCK, don't you fucking daaaaaare
(Mark realizes he might be fucked) Don't you
fucKING DAARE! Alright it's OK yeah
FUCK YOU and ALSO
We have the recipe to be able
to build us a P.R.A.W.N ( 0w0 ) and that means
that we're gonna be able to (Mark's brain just dies) we're gonna
be able to dig up all these big deposits of
that thing and that thing. Whatever the hell those are
Crunch that into meat(Who wants sand shark burgers?), blast that,
basically we're gonna be able to have all of
necessary materials we could possibly want. We'll
never be wanting for anything ever again and we'll be
totally happy in all of our lives. OK So we got
have the names on the lockers first one goes out to
"sarahjohnston1" who said:
"Hey Mark! Make sure you don't your base too big
the larger they are the more likely
the wildlife is to attack it, apparently".
Now I've never been able to
actually make a base underwater
big enough to ever experience this,
but I'm gonna try that In a
future episode I'm definitely gonna try to make the biggest
base that I possibly can because I wanna
see what is going to attack it. NEXT goes up
to POMAH, uh- it's a Russian name that I can't pronounce
but I only see POMAH there
who said:"Mark have you ever thought about playing Subnautica in VR? It's supported in the game
please make a VR special episode."
Now here in my, uh, "recording room"
which is just basically a converted bedroom,
I do not have any VR stuff here
but in the office, I actually do
so I'm may be able to, at some point
experience... THE HORROR, that is the OCEAN, (marks a big baby)
in full Virtual Reality, which I think will be more terrifying
than any other horror game that I've ever played on VR.
Hughstout8 says: "Key rules for Subnautica:
Rule number 1, don't forget about breathing!
Rule number 2, DON'T. FORGET. ABOUT. BREATHING
and Rule number 3, don't ever. Ever. EVER.
forget about any of the Leviathans, whether they be Dragon, Emperor, or Reaper."
Now I don't think the Emperor Leviathan is in the game just yet,
or at least not fully implemented in the game,
but the Dragon, definitely is.
But, we're gonna get to that eventually because we got STUFF to do,
*I*, have the ability to make a P.R.A.W.N,
but I'm pretty sure that's in the Deployables thing now.
Let me look at the recipe for that.
it needs Aluminum Oxide, Plasteel Aerogel and Lubricant
and I don't know how to make Aerogel.......
"Spore Sack and Aluminum Oxide", okay I can do that,
I know where to get Spore Sacks anyway,
but that's not important because RIGHT NOW,
I wanna show you guys, the new thing. And I'm
pretty sure, it's on this other island.
The second island that's actually not an island
It's just, a mountain, under water, that has grown too big for its britches
so we're gonna go over there first,
and I'm gonna take a look at all this Precursor bullshit
because APPARENTLY it's pretty intense,(That voice crack though)
and apparently- oh hey- apparently, it's uhh, pretty ridiculous
and it has something to do,
with how the Aurora got shot down.
I mean if I'm not mistaken by the- the screenshots that I've seen,
it's literally a gun.
i-it's not a temple, it's LITERALLY like a GUN
straight outta Halo, that's what it looks like
and, I'm not a hundred percent sure about this
because I've never seen it with my own TWO EYES
if you guys gonna witness it with me, for the first time
with our own TWO EYES
our collective 2.4 million eyeballs, give or take a few here and there,
are gonna witness this for the first time.
and, I don't know what's gonna happen after that, but
I think it's gonna be amazing! ...maybe.
Also, I'm still recovering just a little bit from being sick
but I'm almost a 100% better
Okay. O-WOOOW! *surprise madafaqa*
(I don't know what to write here)
HI!
*CONCERNS VIOLENTLY*
THAT IS A GUN!
.....is that a gun? That is a 100% a gun!
That's like, straight up a gun!(Yes, it is a gun)
Okay, well now we know what shot down the fuckin Aurora, holy shit!
Okay let me take a look at the underwater portion
before I actually go up to the upper portions
oh my god!
*impressed markimoo is processing*
That's amazing!
I mean this is legitimately alien technology here
what kind of alien species,
put a GUN, in the middle of the goddamn ocean?
and this is legitimately a GUN! (Yes, we know that it's a gun)
I mean, some sort of installation, but, like-
I'm- I'm not mistaken here, this looks straight outta Halo- what is this?
Hello!
These, anchoring point or these power substation or something like that
Ooooh that's SOOO COOL! And kinda creepy and scary...
Why is this just...here? Why is it anchored into the very bedrock?
I- I have no idea why this/these floating- I have so many questions
and I can only assume that gonna be answered by going inside of this thing
if I CAN go inside of this thing.
I better be able to go inside of this thing
they better not put a big old alien building and
no way to actually go inside it
Oh, is that a- ooh- eeh- sorry! Sorry fishies!(Fish:2016-2016)
Sorry, sorry!
Hello! Reinforced dive
suit fragment... that sounds good!
Can I have that? is that gonna make me have
less damage from shit?
Oh no... purple-
PURPLE ARTIFACT?!
Is that in any way related to the
purple guy?! ..."Algae growth on the
exterior of this device indicated it has
lain here for hundreds of years undesturbed.
Despite its age, its power source
appears to be functional. It may
prove to be compatible with other
nearby technologies."
Whaaaat?
Awesome! Oh, theres
a purple sign, with my human
brain i can determine: I need
to get the Purple Artifact,
and put it in the purple
thing! ...I'm the purple guy...
"This device appears to be alien in origin
and is connected to a nearby forcefield.
The technology is far beyond anything
encountered before the federation.
Nonetheless, it appears to be functioning like a
normal lock, it only needs the correct kind
of key." Oookay.....?
That makes
sense.....?
So,
I just have to find the
rest of the purple fragments,
to be able to unlock the
lock, and go inside the
gun. So there's gotta be a way to do it
because they not only gave me one of them,
they also gave me a key hole.
Is that in my recipe book? Do i know how to do this?
Ion crystal and two diamonds.
I dont even know how to make a fuckin Ion
crystal! How am I gonna be able to do that?!
All right so I got some exploring to do
I need to find diamonds which I know I can find on this island
But before I do that I'm going to pop over to the other side of the island here
hmm, ok
popping a squat over the other side here, is there another force field or some doodle daddle
over here
no, no, no not at all, just camping out on there
alright is there a way onto... ah there is
hello, hello, hello everybody my name is Markiplier
can I scan you
hello markiplier here mind if I scan you?
Oh come on now don't be shy
okay
(mark's brain dies... again)
oh, oh cool I didn't even need to build the thing I just got a purple artifact
Well good thing I looked instead of actually trying to do work with my life
OK so...
all right here we go!
Whabooski
yay, did I do it?
Have I done it?
HUZZAH
I did it I think
Scans indicate this structure is composed of a metal allow with unprecedented integrity
No match is found in the database. Performing structural analysis
okay
Well this is bizzare
This is like the biggest mood shift in the entirety of subnautica I've ever seen
this is literally and alien establishment built here hundreds of years ago
and as far as we know is completely abandoned but the technology is still, even though it's ancient
far beyond anything we're capable of
and now I'm getting flashbacks to like quake
anybody remember the first levels of quake
kinda look like this
ooh a green terminal
I wonder what I'm supposed to be able to do here
Identified a background message being broadcast throughout the facility.
Partial translation available. Message reads:
Warning: unidentified craft in orbit of this planet will be destroyed
fa prevent the rocktaget tylenid infasuden
ok so these are german aliens is that what I'm supposed to believe?
Are they viking aliens?
Unknown language attempting translation
I don't know how you're going to be able to do that with no reference data you would be able to actually
like translate anything
allright
this terminal was discovered within the alien city that was shot down, that shot down the aurora on planet 4546B
on approach it began to resonate
producing a low frequency radio wave containing complex but recognisable data patterns
matches no known technology
constructed from the same off world material as the facility itself
seems to be a solid state computer of some kind
no recognisable user interface
it is like
(grunt)
it is likely the alien species which designed this technology
evolved or genetically sensored apparatus to hear and understand the information being broadcast by the device
and to communicate back
The mental processing power required to perform this kind of telepathy
would imply the designers are considerable more psychologically developed than the common human
using the evidence gathered from this device
it may be possible to extract comprehensible data from other such devices should they exist
assessment: further alien data required
now this is fascinating
this is literally us discovering an alien species and I don't know if in the universe of subnautica we've ever discovered an alien species
analysis of the patters on the walls cannot ascertain whether their purpose is aesthetic or function, further data required
let's just assume they planned every minute detail of this entire facility
and that every intricate pattern on the walls serves a function
your best probability of disabling this facility is achieved by accessing the control room in the lower section
how do you know there's a control room in the lower section?
I mean thank you for the clue and all that
but, oh no
I'm going to pick this up
it's an ion crystal
let me scan it and then grab it with my bare hands
oh boy
all right, got one
Oh
it's a minecraft doodad
what the hell does that do?
can I get some information on the ion crystal
these alien cubes can store the equivalent energy of a small nuclear detonation
ahhhh, why am I holding this?
why would I be holding this?
Someone take this from me
I NEED AN ADULT!
the alien technology is able to keep this stored atoms in a permanently stable state
However under the right conditions could be catalyzed and the energy released in a controlled manner
They reuse like batteries, storing power generated in the main reactor and then transport it wherever they needed it
Assessment: possible source of escape velocity energy
Oooooh!
I'm on board with that considering the aurora's engines esploaded
Ok then further down
this is still, like, absolutely fascinating
this is a monumental occasion but why put this here to automatically destroy
any ship that came into orbit of this planet
like it just automatically did it, it's guarding something here
something more
is here
like there is obviously more to this than meets the eye
not only would there be aliens here but there, they put this gun here for a reason
and if it's not guarding something then what is it trying to do
is it trying to keep people out?
Is it trying to stop people from going further
is it trying to protect what's left?
is it trying to selectively filter out the unworthy?
like what is the reasoning here
I guess we'll find out
unknown language. attempting translation.
yep do dat
alien weapon schematic
can I kill a leviathan now?
this data set appears to be multi dimensional schematic for some kind
by mapping the pattern to 3 dimensional space it is possible gather the basic understanding of the super weapons internal workings
Which may help identify a way to disable it
construction material with facilities unknown constructions materials identified as ultra hard, non- reactive metal amalgum
systhesised from off world materials
there is no indication that it can be damaged or destroyed by known means
power
the schematic indicates the weapon was to be powered by a separate self-sustaining power plant located elsewhere on the planet
the location is not listed but there is evidence the design was intended to harness the planets natural thermal energy
the facility consists of the upper engineering section where the schematic was found in the control room which is access via the security sealed  elevator shaft
after a separate underwater moon pool
there's a moon pool in here, is there? haha
the control room in the lower section has the only known way to interfere with the weapon
however the schematic does not detail the operation procedure or installed security measures
so obviously these aliens don't want people fiddling with there giant gun
I mean if I had a giant gun on some random planet I wouldn't want some off worlders fiddling with it and destroying that
I put a lot work in, ahhh
hello (screams)
ok this is gentle
I've got a tingling down in my sousen regions
re, re, my southern reasoning regions
okay, hello
oh ya hello
I don't have any more artifacts left
do I need to go build another artifact before I actually go deeper?
because I can do that
I just need to make two diamonds because I have two ion crystals so that means I should be able to make more artifacts so long as I get enough diamonds
ok I'ma do dat
bye
WEEEEEEEE!
Oh it's day, how lovely
okay so I'm gonna hunt down some diamond but I'm also discovered that in these caves inside this mountain there's actually more
like there's more alien construction in here
I don't know if it's only for lighting or if they kind of devised some kind of power ray that's strewn throughout this mountain?
I can only theorise at this point and I'm only getting gold where is the god damn diamond?
There it is
I need 4
ooh
I found the cave of lithium, apparently
oh what is that?
hello (singing)
I found something, okay good, good, yes, what?
What is this?
Is it a gateway?
oh, insert fuel crystal
okay, I thought I needed one of those
WHAT IS THAT?
WHAT DID I FIND?
Is that a portal?
Do I walk through it?
Oh boy here we go
This structure is currently powered down and it's intended purpose is unclear, possible theories
ceremony or religious role, industrial applications or advanced transportation network
it may be prudent to search the area for further examples of alien architecture and technology
well I've powered it
so you know that's a thing
should I just waltz in there without any care or thought about my own safety
just with reckless abandon, ponder forward and here we go, okay, I'm going in
HA!
(screams) my brain, my brain
(screams)
Am I okay?
Is this all right?
Where am I now?
Oh
Am I in the same place I was?
Where am I?
It kind of seems like the same island but maybe it's not?
Am I on the other island?
WHAT?
I am!
I'm on the other island
What? That's nuts
Holy shit, we got an instant transportation between the both islands
Oh my god
that's awesome
Well that's awfully convenient
now I can be able to go wherever I want
I can build 2 bases but I don't need to be over here right now
that's awfully convenient
well hell yeah
Well I mean good
Did I take fall damage?
Did they finally implement fall damage?
Those sacks of shit
God damn it
All right anyway I found another purple artifact so we're good to go on that front
All right so what I'm going to do is I'm going to go back into the building and I'm going to use this other purple artifact
if this doesn't get me all the way down to the bottom I'm going to have to cut the episode there  but I wanna see what's inside this structure
and now that I have a key I don't have to cut the episode there and I can actually keep going down
Ah, Ah do not fall and die
DO NOT FALL AND DIE
That is bad, that is very bad to fall and die
And hopefully, maybe there's some sort of alien med bay where they're going to heal me up
with some sexy alien babes
one can dream
Woaho, shwoopdy poopdy
Ready to get my grundle tickled, here we go
I, I, I
I mean it's pretty interesting that I'm just so bravely venturing into this thing
I mean I don't know why but I am
Okay, here we go
Got this one, haboof
Hiboofsky
I don't know why these are completely unusable after I put them in
okie doke
cool
woah
It is a moon pool
it legitimately is a moon pool
Woah
should I bathe in this?
Oh my god
is that
is that door open now?
Can I dock my cyclops in here
I'm a I'm just gonna go out and I'm gonna find out where this is so that I can
Oooh
scary
okay
All right so
Ah!
Ahhhh, leave the water alone, I hate that
Ah! okay so I'm assuming that the door opened once I put the key in there and that's going to be good because that allows me to get in here more readily instead of taking the long walking route
this is just fascinating
what kind of ship, some kind of alien underwater vessel  did they have
that helped us or helped them explore the under water depths
cause there's a lot to explore
holy shit
and possibly if I get enough of these chunks I should be able to power my base like indefinitely right? that should be an option
but I'll go up there in just a second I'm gonna see what's over here first
it's easy to get lo.. Oh my god
it's another teleporter
where does this one go?
is it even active?
I wanna go!
where does it go?
Oh I want to know
Do you do something? Hello!
My name is Markiplier
Please open for me?
Do you know who I am?
Do you know how many subscribers I have?
A lot
I better not dehydrate while I'm down here because I'm gonna be very pissed
I'm a be very pissed
Oh is that another key?
It's another key!
Thank you
Well thank you very much
Well that's awfully helpful
If I had known there were so many keys lying around I would never even had to made one
Well I didn't make one so I don't know why I'm complaining
But I got one!
At least this going to be able to explore a little further
Oh my god
Scan indicate the weapon's control room lies beyond this doorway
So I'll be able to control the weapon?
Or at least turn it off
I don't think, I don't think anyone should have that kind of power
this is my planet now!
No rescue ship shall come for me!
I don't need the comfort of humans I've got the comfort of fish
All right so got that, got that, got that
Hello can I break you?
Oh it's that easy
boop!
boink
Ow!
My hand!
Don't probe me
please
ah don't, OH GOD
Ouch
ouch, jeezums
Warning infected individuals may no disable  the weapon this planet is under quarantine
infected?
infected with what!?
is this going to be some kind of like curse of flesh
Oh
there's another facility
there is legitimately another facility here in this vicinity and if it's under 800 metres that can only mean that it is in the inactive lava zone
where the dragon leviathan is
and that's bad, that's very bad
because I don't know if I want to fight the dragon leviathan
but for some reason we've discovered  the humans
I, I don't think this a thing where I'm infected like I got it when I'm here I think this means the humans in general are infected
with something that this alien race considers to be a disease  and that may be like the curse of life or something like that
but it's something deeper here and this mystery is fascinating
So anyway that is all the time I have for this episode  but this is just intriguing
I have no idea how deep this goes but I have a roadmap for what I'm going to be able to do
In the next few episodes I'm going to
Number 1 build the prawn suit
Number 2 go build a cyclops
Number 3 build a better base and better launching pad for me to go and explore  deeper and darker in the depths of subnautica
but this is fascinating
I have no idea what we're going to find in the other alien facilities
OH MY GOD IT IS DARK!
AH
Why did I park my seamoth so far away?
But anyway I've got a plan for the next few episodes
but I don't know where this road is going to lead and I am so happy that I started back up when I did because this is the perfect time to explore the mystery of the actual story
Let me know what you guys think down in the comments below, what is this all mean? Where is this going to go?
Who is this alien race? Is it some sort of robotic race  that doesn't like organic life? Is it something where there's a race that thinks there so superior
that genetic inferiority is treated as a disease?
I don't know
But I wanna hear your thoughts so let me know down in the comments below
and thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh bye!